all right here's the story ladies and
gentlemen today Donald Trump arrived in
Washington DC pleaded not guilty
political reports Trump pleads not
guilty to charges that he conspired to
overturn the 2020 election and the
former president's arraignment
prosecutors and defense lawyers signaled
immediate disagreement over how quickly
he should stand trial so my
understanding is I think that they have
it in here somewhere the next date will
be August 28th was that it did they even
how far down do I got to go for them to
confirm it but I'm pretty sure here we
go chidcon's first hearing was set for
August 28th before then prosecutors and
Trump's defense team were ordered to
submit briefs proposing a schedule for
the trial chitcon expects a to set a
trial date at the August 28th hearing
Trump criticized Chicana in a social
media post a few hours before
calling her unfair so apparently the
reporting is that Jack Smith is trying
to try this extremely quickly saying we
need a speedy trial here probably
because the primaries are coming up and
uh you know there's another story we'll
get into Rhonda Santos debating Gavin
Newsom I kind of feel like that's what
the Deep state is hoping for Gavin
Newsom not Joe Biden and Rhonda Sanders
not Donald Trump I am not trying to
imply that either of them are working
for the Deep State or the intelligence
agencies I'm saying that they don't want
a failing Joe Biden because he can't win
and they despise Donald Trump so they're
trying to get whatever they can thus
Jack Smith is like let's get this speedy
and and rushed through but uh I wanna
I'll add one thing before we all just
jump into the conversation
I think the fact that they did not
remind Trump to custody proves it is not
a legitimate criminal trial
and people can make the argument oh no
Trump's not a Flight Risk nobody thinks
he'll flee he's running for president
it's like okay fair point but they're
accusing him of trying to overthrow the
government that's what they're saying on
MSNBC this guy owns a 757 a Cessna
Citation he owns two helicopters he
apparently he probably has access to
more Jets than just those not to mention
being a billionaire he can easily
Charter a private jet if they
legitimately thought Trump was a threat
to democracy and that he was trying to
overthrow the government
how could they not order him to to be
remanded
it just makes me start to wonder like
who are his Secret Service agents and
where are their loyalties you know what
I mean like who do they think that
they'll just be like no no we won't let
you flee if you really wanted to I'm
sure he could figure it out uh the
entire case against Trump and I made
this argument the other night was it
it's obviously intended to destroy the
pattern and uh momentum of his campaign
right Jack Smith was happily
investigating for years and then all of
a sudden he's ready and we have to rush
this prosecution doesn't seem suspicious
at all oh wait of course it's complete
convenience Trump could go to his jumbo
jet and say we're going to do a route we
have a scheduled rally in insert City
Milwaukee and then they all get on the
plane and then as soon as the plane
takes off he goes to the pilot and says
we're going the El Salvador and then you
know people could argue like oh there's
no flight dude he could just do it they
could you just do it the problem is if
he left excuse me uh he wouldn't be able
to be president of course that would
burn the bridge and I know he doesn't
want to burn that bridge the sort of
considerable Flight Risk I I don't buy
it they're they're accusing Trump of
some of the most serious crimes in the
history of this country they are
claiming that he attempted to steal
they're claiming that he he called for
an Insurrection to Stage a coup on the
capitol to to steal power that is that
is seditious they're they're effectively
arguing whether they didn't charge
charging for uh charge him with it or
not seditious conspiracy and then being
like nah you're good go on home buddy I
don't I don't here's what I think though
I think that we're missing one little
point I agree with you that it's
obviously not serious charges if they
actually thought he was a threat they
would have kept him in pre-trial
detention just like they did with so
many of the January 6th exactly that
which I thought was setting a legal
precedent so that they could do this
with Trump I still think they're going
to I don't think that just because they
let him walk out today that that means
that they're not going to I think they
obviously want to put Trump in prison
because they despise Trump they think
it'll destroy his presidential campaign
but if you look at the Crux of what this
indictment from Jack Smith in is is it's
really against political speech it's a
violation of your First Amendment right
to have an opinion that is different
than the opinion of the Joe Biden
Administration which we can talk about
the trickle-down effects of that but I
think that they want to criminalize not
just Trump's Free Speech they want to
criminalize us so how do they do that
well they wait until this story's passed
he tweets something they disagree with
they say it's you know ruining this case
they put them in pre-trial detention
because they want some crazed Trump
supporter to commit an act of violence
so that they can say well it's not just
it's not just a crime when Trump says
this it's a crime when all you all say
this and we're going to crack down on
you I think there could be a component
to that I think part of the Free Speech
angle or the the criticism of political
speech is that they never got a Smoking
Gun there's really nothing there so now
they're gonna have to make a very uh
obscure political argument uh I think if
Trump you're totally right if he fled
the country he couldn't be president it
would obviously worse I think part of it
is sort of gambling with them they
really want the perp walk they want an
image of him in handcuffs they want that
to be all you see for a long time uh and
so again for me all of this comes back
to timing right they could do it right
now but he's gaining every time they
indict him he he jumps in the polls so
if they released a picture from in
handcuffs who's to say this wouldn't
actually bolster his supporters it would
help exactly that's why they won't
remand them that's my point if they
genuinely thought Trump tried to
overthrow this country and Lead an
Insurrection against uh artificial
proceeding they'd be like lock them up
and throw away the key there are people
still in jail right now without charge
or trial for having trespassed at the
Capitol and you mean to tell me that
they're like Trump you are free to go
but we think you're the one who
orchestrated all of it nah yeah think
about it they don't believe it at all
think about the Q Anon Shaman right
Jacob chansley like think about we all
saw that video when when Tucker aired it
after McCarthy gave him all the film
from January 6th like you can make an
argument that he shouldn't have been in
the capital like that's fine but
obviously not violent right he was just
kind of Meandering around in there and
he was kept in in pre-trial detention
and then in prison for how long because
he was considered to be he was
considered to be it was the same charge
that one of the same charges that Trump
is obstruction of an official government
proceeding yeah and he I mean come on I
mean the same thing with like the proud
boy conspiracy trial it's crazy I will
say because you brought it up uh you
know we felt like the January 6 you know
imprisonment was sort of a sense of
President and it makes me wonder is
there a fear among uh left-leaning and
Democrat left-leaning lawmakers and
Democrats that eventually Republicans
will go after maybe Hillary Clinton or
someone else and then if they put Trump
in jail right now then they are setting
the president that their leaders will
have to go in jail at the same point
during the trial uh maybe this is a sign
that they're actually scared
maybe I don't think they have anything
to worry about Democrats going to jail
and Republicans are in power
unfortunately I agree I agree
Republicans are going to send strongly
worded letters and then yeah it's just
the most pathetic pathetic thing
imaginable the the the the
the indictment against Donald Trump Lays
uh lays forth this this idea that you
can indict someone for defrauding this
country over elections
so where is where are any of the
Republican DA's anywhere in this country
to indict Hillary Clinton
for for acid washing or servers well I
mean she was she she's publicly stated
over and over again that Trump was
illegitimate and she was doing it to try
and you know steal power and all of
these things she was call accusing Trump
of being a Russian during the election
oh all right all right you know 2015 the
the all of the stuff that they started
pulling out against Donald Trump
accusing of working with Russians and
being a Russian asset and all this stuff
that was that was before Trump won
limitations on that I can't imagine it's
it's only a couple years got to be at
least 10 right it's felony maybe there's
no statute where's any Republican to be
like okay we're filing charges but the
jurisdiction touches everything it's
legal to say that you think uh an
election was fraudulent if you truly not
according to the indictment but only
again the indictment's basically saying
that Trump's opinion even though he
genuinely believed it no no no the
indictment says that Trump stated things
that he knew were false therefore it's
illegal it's pretty obvious to everyone
that Trump believed what he was saying
sure and let's make the same argument
that Hillary Clinton knew she was lying
the same as they say about Trump and go
arrest her own Republicans are pathetic
spineless whiny losers you can't prove
if they knew it or not there's no way of
course that's actually that's actually
one of the biggest flaws I think besides
the attack on the First Amendment that's
one of the biggest legal flaws is this
the the bar for the intent in these
different statutes is so high I I mean
it's it's arguably unconstitutional but
it would be next to impossible to prove
if you had unbiased jurors which I
suppose is a huge caveat in this case
because it's going to be in Washington
DC so not unless Trump gets in West
Virginia which I would personally love
there's no way that's gonna happen the
best thing of all time he for sure I
mean I don't know but he really seems to
believe like that election was
fraudulent he's very straightforward
about it he's been the entire time I
don't understand why they would assume
that he's lying it makes sense they're
not assuming he's lying they are lying
they're purporting that he's lying I
suppose they they know Trump really
believes it but they're lying and so the
issue is
why is it that Vivek ramaswamy is filing
his lawsuits against the doj for
information pertaining to the
communications between Biden and Garland
as per this uh this indictment why is it
Vivek he's not even a politician and
he's more effective than whatever
Republican I'll give Matt Gates a pass
he's doing a lot of really great stuff
he's always on top of stuff but vivek's
just a candidate and he's like I'm gonna
file a lawsuit can we get a single
member of Congress to do something no
they're too busy holding hearings so
they can get viral Twitter Clips Tim
yeah that's about much more important
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time